[Music]
hello and welcome back to the hot ones
Museum of curiosities
I'm your curator Sean Evans here to show
off some new exhibits like the quarter
water signed by Jesus and Mero we have a
jug of milk signed by Jimmy Butler and
of course stolen right from my bedside
it's a framed picture of me and
Shaquille O'Neal artifacts from the
season that was and that's why we're
here to talk about season eight and
we'll begin of course in controversy
corner Shaquille O'Neal does he belong
on the wall of shame on the last wing
we have bets we have side bets we have
double downs and eventually it's like
well where does it all end
does anyone belong in the wall of shame
because he started with wings ten to
nine and didn't eat the rest should Tyra
Banks be on The Wall of shame because
she tapped in camera guy bill to eat her
Mad Dog wing should the nibblers of
Nipplegate all be banned to the wall of
shame themselves maybe I don't know it's
just there's too much responsibility and
power to bear when you're adjudicating a
chicken wing talk show but listen we
hear you and we will be doing a full
audit of our Wall of shame protocol to
figure out how we're gonna operate going
forward Christian burger his laptop has
already been subpoenaed camera guy bill
he's been sequestered no collusion going
forward in controversy corner who gate
Billy Eilish who off set whoo-hoo-hoo
our humble hope is that even if you
don't know the guest there's no better
way to get to know them then over the
wings of death and honestly the fan
feedback that I love the most because
when someone's like you know I didn't
know who this person was going in but
now I'm a fan I love when granny lidia
christian burgers 92 year old grandma
sends her review emails and talks about
how much she liked the offset episode or
how my friend Trent's dad Pete shoutout
Pete is listening to the Billy Eilish
album because he liked her hot ones
episode you know it's a wild expectation
to think that every single thing you
watch is gonna be tailored to your
specific tastes and interests
all right that's enough of that rant
that's enough of my whining that's
enough of my passive-aggressive
lecturing to the fans because now it's
time to get into the season 8 QA Chris
hit me with the bucket o season 8
questions man he has been waiting to do
that for months there's some creaking
back here alright first question B M
part 12 asks which interviews are you
most proud of if that's too difficult
which ones were the craziest I think
that Gordon Ramsay given the
expectations and the way that we
executed against those expectations
proud of the team for that one another
one is John Mayer you know I'm always
partial to when somebody is kind of
dragged in the media for years and years
maybe people see a different side of
them on hot ones that's something that
we take pride in and then in the same
way I think that Russell Brand is
another episode that it was the same
thing you know people whine and complain
when they see the thumbnail and then
they fall in love with the episode so
when we're kind of able to win people
over when it's Anarchy in the comments
those are the times that I'm proud when
we deliver a good episode denis ivanov
asks what are the most annoying YouTube
comments to you ultimately they are what
they are and I can live with pretty much
all of them you know I feel like it's
just my job to like make the thing and
then put it out it's not up to me to
decide like what it is or what it is and
people decide what syncs what floats
whatever but I know that if you trace
the IP address to the person who
announces when they're unsubscribing or
when they're not watching I know that if
you trace that IP address it goes back
to somebody who I could not share a car
with for five minutes you know that's
all I know why are they being so
dramatic about it it's like they think
that we're gonna be like flyers fanned
8282 and then we like break glass like
we're gonna lose them we're gonna lose
them and then all of a sudden were like
we're pelling down the side of his house
and be like come on man what do we need
to do to keep you in here you know
there's no reason to be that dramatic
just don't watch like other humans
all right Lucas Middleton asks which is
our in case you have what the which is
/r in case you have your favorite movies
and why difficult to answer because I'm
a movie guy I am very much papa Chiba qu
Papa Moonrock settle into the love sack
and see where this night takes us I am
very much visiting the ArcLight
rewards points member cashing them in
for fanny packs and free popcorns but
let me give you what I think were some
of the best movies that I saw this year
black Klansmen Spider Man eighth grade
hereditary Florida project and then
let's give a few honorable mentions to a
star is born and searching that's just
off the top of the dome I'm getting a
validating head nod from camera guy bill
what are your guys favorite movies put
them in the comments all right up next
from our former intern Alex Rockefeller
what's the weirdest fan interaction
you've ever had recently somebody sent
us a personal check with a nice note
that was like I just like to support
good content this is like here's 50
bucks like in a personal check so that
was interesting and awesome I wish more
people were like that like that just be
like just watching something back I like
to support them here's and then they
just empty out their wallet here's 25
bucks
look at that was awesome TSA agents were
big with the TSA I'll always get these
dad jokes from TSA agents where they're
like pulling you aside I'm gonna Pat you
down sir you don't have to bomb on you
do you like they do stuff like that you
don't have any death sauce on you any
death wings yeah they do that that has
happened on more than one occasion Kevin
O'Donnell asks in Shawn's opinion what's
the most underrated episode guest to
date and Shawn's opinion Trick Daddy how
you doing in this Parker goat episode up
next what is the one question you always
get asked and get tired of answering
that's easy you know a lot of people how
do you do it how is your butthole what
are your shits like you know like that
you know after the first 10,000 of those
questions then you know eventually and
now I'm like shell-shocked
yeah this guy's everything's good thank
you thank you okay can you be a little
raw butthole is on my snapchat this one
comes from Ben mandap did Gordon ever
come through with the wing sponsorship
no but everyone thinks so which is funny
which is funny about the Internet
everyone's like have you notice the
wings look so much better since Gordon's
been on the show Gordon must have
sponsored the wings no they've been the
same wings like for I don't know like
four or five seasons now it's just been
my belly's plateless but it is funny
that people think that when Gordon came
that he sponsored the wings and other
totally new wings they've been the same
wings now for quite some time all right
Jonathan Thayer asks after Ramsay who is
the most popular guest request from fans
we haven't got to yet you see Tyler the
Creator all the time Will Smith all the
time Joe Rogan all the time
Elon Musk increasingly so you know when
you when you catch one white whale seven
eight nine ten others pop up so that's
why we got to just keep going just keep
traveling just keep popping this thing
up all right
the Josh Minh asks soft or hard tacos
listen I don't care if it's soft or hard
as long as it's a corn tortilla I think
that corn tortilla softshell tacos are
the ideal taco from me hardshell tacos
also delicious better from the top from
the hot one subreddit how did you guys
hire your editor Colin the story of
Colin Higgins is an inspirational one
and one I hope I tell for years so
basically Colin used to do these hot
ones meme videos and the one that came
to our attention was hot ones Tyra Banks
but Sean's a serial killer so we saw
this video we laughed we passed it
around and then kind of turned the page
but then we had an opening for an editor
so we're looking to hire and we kind of
turned it into a contest where all these
people applied and then maybe we
narrowed that field down to 25 and with
those 25 people we sent him the raw
footage from Terry Crews and told them
to recreate a couple wings and whoever
made the wings that are closest to the
Platonic ideal of what we want hot ones
to be that would be the editor that we
hire and then we took like the best of
those three and then we called them in
and one of them was Collins I didn't
even know Colin was the guy who did the
meme thing or anything I was just like
that's pretty good that's pretty funny
this guy's obviously watch the show a
ton and gets it so let's talk to him and
then when we're talking to Colin we
figure out that he's the guy who did the
Tyra Banks meme videos what the [ __ ]
Colin Higgins goes from meme video -
pretty good editor job with Bennie's and
that's the story of Colin your idols
become your rivals we all have to keep
an eye on him we're all gonna be working
for Colin someday all right Anthony Paul
asks what's your favorite hot sauce when
you're not on the show no hot sauce when
I'm not on the show
but if I'm gonna reach into the cabinet
dirty dicks is awesome
I like the torchbearer guys I think they
make amazing sauces but the best is
Queen Majesty I'll go on record Queen
Majesty makes the best hot sauce in the
world all right what would it take for
an ordinary person like myself to get on
your show well you know what it's not my
show it's our show and it's not me you
have to win over it's them it's the
people so don't look at me and be like
what do I have to do to get on the show
look at them and say what do they need
for you to be on the show and there you
have your answer all right that's enough
of the budget Oh season eight questions
another barn burner the Museum of
curiosities is open from 8 a.m. to 5
p.m. Monday through Saturday bring a
canned good and it's half off at mission
until next time we have some fun things
going on
we're never talking about how he'd land
it
you know the drill season 9 coming into
port may 23rd
that's right spice Lords we're taking
about 20 minutes off and then boom
popped in the set back up and it's time
to eat more wings with your favorite
celebrities and before we go it's time
to take a look back on the season that
was season 8 our biggest season to date
by miles and miles laughs and laughs so
thank you so much to the fans who've now
rocked with us through season one
through season two through season three
through season four through season five
through season six through season seven
through season 8 and this season now
roll it
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Chelsea Handler a
hot [ __ ]
whoa it's been too long wait too long
it's been waited in advance so we're
glad we could do it for the community
and for the people I don't want to be
here but I am scared of you not you as a
person right rate talk before you sound
amazing and lovely and nice but I'm
scared of this a little nervous so
finally under immense pressure from the
family and a lot of supporters out there
I'm here thank you for having me here
I'm happy to be here with you and the
and this poultry daddy sorry to handle
mm-hmm
[ __ ] okay now you're just starting
it's going for it just dive in here
I'm doing good you're doing so girl [ __ ]
just be too soon
hey I'm broth it gets real like
something's [ __ ] broke in the back
door you know whoo-whee it snuck up on
me right yeah okay go ahead do you
remember what you were eating when you
tweeted food is such a powerful little
ho good effuse answer any questions on
the grounds of anything
is it reveals any questions alright I'm
beginning to get you to like you oh yeah
well hold on to that thought I don't
want to do the bomb one would be good no
stuffing that's from Kansas Kansas don't
bother doing the hot wings so hot just
thinking wow this is awesome yeah I mean
this is like challenging in a way I've
never experienced this moisturizer
my lips are very crisp rice down and I
don't want to lick them take a lap
scarlet had plenty of laps plenty of
laps this is amazing
does that work are they doing a number
on that picture Kennedy
[Music]
oh my god I don't know if I can recover
you've taken some big punches here oh my
god
I got you burn this together and I know
that you're at this moment yeah what is
that a certain point but I see this
spirited minicar pain and it's not just
the sauce the more you get pushed the
thick your skin the thinking your skin
trust me the higher you go now he
finishes it this is about maybe starting
accomplish go finish this [ __ ] I'm still
connected I'm connected to not
continuing to eat these wings but if you
need me to I will are you doing
what's that happening here this is the
last dab we call it the last step
because the tradition around here to put
a little extra on the last wing oh the
last step that's right oh I'll do it
just this is fun
bottoms up time's up buddy
oh my
the master power survival did they're
super mature to turn what does that need
some hot sauce no a [ __ ] soul
clearing the board I know there was a
time when your back was against the
ropes you didn't think you could but you
did it this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life like right at this
very moment I'm feeling pretty
vulnerable right now I'm not gonna lie
right now I need to say a [ __ ] doctor
[ __ ] yourself
[Music]
you
hey what's going on everybody this is
Sean Evans checking in with a quick hot
sauce update if you'd like to try the
classic Louis calientes the last Abra
Ducks heat nice calm heat nice calm has
you covered if hot sauce isn't your
thing maybe check out a t-shirt or a
hoodie over at shop complex calm and if
none of that interests you I have been
really getting into macho lately matcha
latte as much as smoothies much of
pudding I don't know how I went 32 years
on this planet without discovering
matcha but now I have and it has been a
complete game-changer
we don't sell any matcha products
whatsoever but I'm just saying you
should try it out